صناعه التكنولوجيا في الولايات المتحده
مضطربه مع اعلان الشركات الامريكيه عن
تخفيضات في الوظائف اكثر مما كان متوقعا
في السابق امازون هي احدث شركه تقرر تخفيض
الوظائف وسبقتها الاسبوع الماضي شركه ميتا
الشركه الام لفيسبوك معلنه انها ستلغي ما
يقرب من عشره الاف وظيفه خلال الاشهر
المقبله في الموجه الثانيه من عمليات
التسريح الجماعي للعمال
وللاطلاع على سبب هذه التسريحات سالنا
تشاد الموظف الذي خسر عمله في متى في
الدوره الاولى من التخفيضات لنستمع
اعتقد انها قرارات تجاريه فاشله لا احد
لديه طابه باللوريه يمكن اعتبار ان الشركه
تملكها القليل من الجشع مع الكثير من عدم
اليقين واتخذت بعض القرارات التي لم تكن
رائعه انا لا الوم احد لكن الى جانب ذلك
اتى الوباء الذي جعل الاشياء تبدو مذهله
للقط اع الالكتروني بسبب الطلب المتزايد
حينها
التخوف الان من ان يشكل عدد الموظفين
المسرحين ضغطا كبيرا على القطاع الذي
يكافح الان للبقاء وعلى الاقتصاد الامريكي
بشكل عام هذا ما يقوله ماكس كبير مستشار
سياسه الالكترونيه في معهد
لن اسمي ما يحدث بالازمه انها مهمه ولكنها
ليست ازمه ما يحدث هو تغيير طبيعي من
الاتجاه الاخر من التوظيف الذي قامت به كل
هذه الشركات في هذا الوباء من ميته الى
امازون الى جوجل هناك الكثير من العوامل
المختلفه وليست بسبب الموظفين
عن شركه ابل التي لم تشهد موجه مماثله من
تخفيض الموظفين يقول مايك
ابل هي واحده من اكثر شركات سريه في وادي
السيليكون ومن الصعب جدا مقارنتها بشركات
اخرى سياستها قائمه على حفظ السريه منذ
انشائها على ايدي ستيف جوبز ولديهم ثقافه
فريده من نوعها تقدر سلامه موظفيها
ومشاركتهم المهمات لذا بدا الاعتماد على
تسريح العمال تيم كوك المدير التنفيذي
يبدا بتخفيض راتبه
5003 شركات صرحت حوالي 140 الف موظفا منذ
بدايه 2023 وحتى اللحظه الامر الذي اعتبر
جرس انذار لكل القطاع لاعاده تحديد
الاهداف وتشكيل استراتيجيات جديده تواكب
تحديات ما بعد وباء كورونا
العربيه واشنطن